the ps5 game lineup announcement is
coming soon The Last of Us part 2 is
getting a ps4 Pro bundle and mafia
definitive edition has a release date
I'm sassy and this is your safe State
for Tuesday May 19th Sony is set to
announce the PS 5 game lineup soon the
PS 5 is still slated to launch by end of
year but we haven't seen many confirmed
games at this point during a corporate
strategy meeting Sony stated that it
will quote introduce a compelling lineup
of titles soon normally this sort of
reveal would happen at e3 but Sony
pulled out of that at the start of this
year and now e3 itself isn't happening
current confirmed new PS 5 titles
include Assassin's Creed Valhalla Lord
of the Rings golem and watchdogs Legion
what new games do you want to see on the
PS 5 and speaking of PlayStation Sony
announced a ps4 Pro bundle for the Last
of Us part two the Last of Us part two
is just a month away and Sony has now
debuted a limited edition ps4 pro bundle
that will launch alongside the game the
bundle includes a ps4 pro and controller
that both have the unique design of
Elly's fern tattoo the game and a
digital voucher for a dynamic theme
avatars and other goodies it costs 400
US dollars and 500 canadian dollars the
special edition bundle launches
alongside the game on June 19th does
this special edition ps4 pro interest
you or are you holding out for a PS 5
next up mafia definitive edition now has
a confirmed release date the mafia
trilogy is coming to ps4 Xbox one and PC
via Steam on August 28th you don't have
to wait till then to play some of it
though pre-order and you'll get instant
access to the definitive editions of
mafia 2 and 3 which include all the DLC
and 4k resolution support you can also
buy them for $30 each on console or $40
each on Steam if you already own mafia 2
on Steam you'll get the definitive
edition for free on PC if you own mafia
3 on ps4 or Xbox one you will get that
definitive edition for free on console
as for mafia that is a completely
rebuilt version of the game and you'll
have to wait until August 28th for it it
has an updated script with new dialogue
expanded backstories and additional
cutscenes did you play the original
mafia what are you looking forward to in
the remake heads up because vaults are
open in warzone now the latest update to
Call of Duty warzone is live and it
opens up the mysterious vaults to get
sad you'll need a read access card which
can be obtained from a legendary orange
crate once inside you'll find a ton of
high tier loot giving you a serious
boost in the battle royale there also
seems to be a deeper layer of the vault
that requires an access code to open up
we're exploring the vaults ourselves so
stay tuned the game spot for more
details and strategies and as a reminder
game spots play for all charity event is
coming soon
III might not be happening this year but
we've got you covered starting June 1st
GameSpot is going to be hosting play for
all a multi week event that is going to
be the best place for you to get all the
latest gaming news features interviews
and live streams not only that but we're
also partnering with Direct Relief to
raise funds for health care workers
risking their lives daily on kovat 19
relief efforts we'll have over 100 hours
of Awesome content that will feature the
GameSpot team as well as friends from
across the industry we'll be announcing
who they are soon but you can expect
familiar faces you know and love we hope
you'll join us to celebrate gaming and
raise money for a great cause stay tuned
for more details and that's your safe
stay for Tuesday I'm chastity and you
can find me on GameSpot universe or on
Twitter at chastity underscore V and for
all the latest news stick with GameSpot
you